just got home my nephew - I haven't seen
for months there inside with my sister
Christmas is around the corner and
they're here for a week to spend time
with us let's see the reactions together
this is exciting
they're hanging out with my two boys and
a girl there we go food out there's some
good food my best friend comes first
think that playing piano here we go
hello how are you what you guys doing
see what you're looking like man I hear
you're working out what's happening how
are you let's go see the kids
Lily i Dylan James with Davis will one
day be a great leader okay
big boys I'm a big dude say hello Tom
what's your name John what do you give
me one day what kind of soccer player
that's right a best one are you left
your ID why are you a lefty because
you're special that's why you're letting
Gracie Gracie girl to me Gracie girl how
are you my little pretty face you doing
good
say hi to everybody
Gracie I remember when Gracie when
Gracie was born I was in Cayman Islands
when you were born never forget that
call what's Tico doing Wow
um Tico our Chico say hi what are you we
got the red nose ring your nose is red
let me see this let me see this Lily
where's Emma Billy she's sleeping she's
sleeping huh so you see the tree this
just makes zero sense I keep give my
wife a hard time that tree let me tell
you how tall I am so you can kind of get
an idea I am six four and a half six
five that tells you how tall the tree is
right
our ceiling is 24 25 feet and we got a
six-foot tree do you know what we have a
six-foot tree because in balance we will
gone to New York for a week straight and
we come back to buy Christmas tree and
the tallest Christmas tree was six foot
we needed a 12 foot or 10 foot they
didn't have it so we got a tiny tiny
little tree but the tree doesn't matter
it's what the gifts under the tree that
mattered so anyways hey enjoy your time
during the holiday season I'm enjoying
my my pops when is that coming in by the
way we have some John Mason coming in
Mason coming in you want to go play at
the park here do you know there's a big
difference we can plan out the park in
Texas versus California it's freezing
here right now but we'll see what we can
do maybe I can show you anyways hey
enjoy your holidays spent out your
family enjoy it
because it's always great to have an
excuse to enjoy the time the company of
your family for call back everybody say
bye say bye bye bye bye say bye Billy
Boy Billy Boy say bye say bye
he's so serious take care